introducing software series 7 start your
morning with summon while you get ready
summon your Tesla from your Tesla app
automatically opening the garage pulling
out and closing the garage for you
combining a newly streamlined interface
with the enhanced control and
versatility of your daily commute
over-the-air updates continually improve
and add new features to autopilot
autopilot removes the stress from your
commute designed for highway use
autopilot assists you with the routines
of daily driving whether you're cruising
or crawling to the left and right of the
speedometer find the icons for traffic
aware cruise control an order steer
these appears gray when available and
blue an active use the crew stock to
engage traffic aware cruise control pull
it toward you wants to engage smart
speed and twice to activate auto steer
as well keeping your hands on the wheel
ease back is traffic aware cruise
control maintains your cruising speed
dynamically adjusting in response to
other vehicles auto steer will keep to
the curve of the road
sensing both the lane boundaries and the
surrounding traffic if you wish to
change lanes check for space and signal
as usual this triggers auto lane change
which will merge you safely into the
desired lane to disengage autopilot push
the button on the outside of the cruise
stalk push the stalk forward or press
the brake auto steer can be deactivated
without affecting traffic aware cruise
control by turning the wheel a few
degrees please remember that these
features are meant only for highway use
keep your hands on the wheel at all
times and stay alert
Auto Park completes a suite of autopilot
features as you drive past an open spot
pull about one car lengths ahead and
come to a complete stop but alas will
scan the space and display a P on your
instrument cluster signal and shift to
reverse press start an auto park will
initiate guiding you perfectly into
position
autopilot changes away you relate to
your drive it expands your awareness of
Model S and its surroundings enhances
your ability to respond and gives you
more comfort and energy during and after
your drive